Glucose, sucrose, high fructose!
Sugar, you guys.
It's all so....taxing.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Amidst all of the sensationalism about the
"obesity epidemic", there lies a very important
nugget of information: Americans now consume
39% more added sugars in our food than we
did 50 years ago.
Particularly, we consume waaaaay more high
fructose corn syrup.
This is why some experts say that sugary drinks
like soda, energy drinks, and fruit juice
cocktails are driving their own public health
issues.
This has led scientists to try to figure out
how we can better curb our consumption of
these sugary beverages, and one of the ways
that has been proposed is: higher taxes.
Now even SAYING the word "tax" is generally
divisive one here in the good ol' U-S-of-A,
but a new study has found that a soda tax
might actually come with health benefits.
An international study based at the Health
Economics Centre at Monash University concluded
that by upping the taxes on soda, people will
lose weight -- as much as 8 POUNDS in a year
for those who drink a lot of it.
In their analysis, they compared the economic
effect of 2 types of taxes: the first was
a 20% tax and the second was a 20 CENT tax
per liter of soda.
Both taxes are regressive, which basically
means it affects the poor more than the wealthy,
but those effects aren't overly pronounced
in the study.
With a 20% tax, the effect impacts all consumption
levels with a similar force, whereas the benefit
of a 20 CENT tax is that the tax burden increases
when you buy more of the drinks.
For the 20% tax, people are projected to lose
about 3 pounds, or 1.3 kilos, in a year.
Those who drink A LOT of soda could see that
number doubled.
The 20 cent tax had a more dramatic effect,
kicking off an 8 pound weight loss, or 3.6
kilos, in a year.
This was only for the middle class though.
Why?
Researchers at Duke found that for the rich,
they're still gonna buy the soda either way.
For the poor, they're more likely to strategize
-- things like buying in bulk or waiting for
sales.
So for both these groups, the health effects
aren't as likely to kick in as the middle
class.
While these studies both find some health
benefits, other studies have found that taxes
WON'T encourage healthier habits.
A recent study by health economists at the
University of Iowa found that just because
people are drinking less soda doesn't mean
that they won't find more calories elsewhere.
So, what do YOU think about a soda tax?
Is it worthwhile if there's a public health
benefit?
Or should people be encouraged to drink less
soda on their own -- without the deterrence
caused by taxes?
Let me know what you think down below, and
we'll be back soon with more DNews updates.